the Democrats long march into
irrelevance that's the focus of
tonight's angle we have not seen one
scrap of evidence demonstrating that
President Trump or his campaign colluded
with the Russians well that's a big
letdown for Democrats who expected to
have Trump either convicted or impeached
by this point so now what do they do
well if you can't beat them sue them
well believe it or not the Democratic
National Committee filed a lawsuit today
against the Russian government
the Trump campaign and the WikiLeaks
organization oh that's all they allege
get this a far-reaching conspiracy to
throw the 2016 election to Donald Trump
yes I'm serious well I'm surprised at
this point they didn't sue CNBC for
airing Apprentice reruns that's not fair
look should we really be surprised by
any of this the rage and the fury on the
left over Trump's election in their
frantic search for something anything to
explain why Hillary Clinton lost has
become a total obsession they thought
collusion would invalidate the election
there is however extensive press
reporting on the relationships between
the Russians and the individuals
associated with both the Trump campaign
and the incoming administration we know
the Russians played a very significant
role in the campaign so you have seen
direct evidence of collusion I don't
want to go into specifics but I will say
that there is evidence that is not
circumstantial I've always said that I
believe there was collusion poor auntie
Maxine after all these months and after
a special counsel and congressional
investigations too numerous to count
what have they actually found a
multimillion-dollar pile of nothing well
good luck to the DNC and trying to make
a case in court with these star
witnesses have you seen any evidence
that this dirt these emails were ever
given to
Trump campaign not so far any reflection
of collusion between members of the
Trump campaign and the Russians there
was no evidence of that included in in
our report I understand it but does it
exist not to my knowledge when you
learned of Russian efforts did you have
evidence of a connection between the
Trump campaign and Russian state actors
as I said mr. Gowdy I don't do evidence
yeah there's a lot apparently that John
Brennan doesn't do what that is just a
joke now just imagine the discovery
process if this foolishness ever made it
to trial like what if the defense
demands to see the DNC servers that they
claim WikiLeaks hacked you know the
servers the Democrats refused to let the
FBI examine and that the FBI for some
strange reason neglected to subpoena
what's on those servers the DNC is so
desperate to keep hidden
and also how about this scene on the
witness stand
does the name Christopher steel ring a
bell mrs. Clinton how about his dossier
and does the DNC really want to go down
this road for a media apparatus that has
been predicting huge wins for months
some evidence for Democrats to be
optimistic at their chances for a big
blue waves the big blue wave is now
looking so big so overwhelming and we
fell short but next year watch out next
year's is gonna be a blue wave well this
absurd lawsuit which reads like it was
written by a first-year law student
shows that Democrats aren't sure the
wave may not just flatten out before it
hits the shore at this point when you
really look at the totality of all of us
rather than looking like a party that
has the wind that it's back this year
the Democrats increasingly look like a
party desperately trying to find its own
identity and relevance as Trump
meanwhile chalks up win after win on
things like trade North Korea and yes
the economy
now my personal advice to Democrats is
this keep doing what you're doing
because the American people are a lot
smarter than you give them credit for
and I actually look forward to their
final ruling on this latest complaint of
the Democrats and all those that
preceded it come this November